let's say we're in r2 let me graph it
let me draw my vertical axis just like
that and then let me draw my horizontal
axis just like that and let's say I have
a vector let me call let's say I have a
vector to the vector 1 2 so my vector
looks like this 1 then we go up 2 so my
vector looks like this then let me draw
it that is my vector it's the vector 1 2
and I want to look at the line that is
spanned by this vector so let me just
define some line L and it's equal to the
set of T times 1 2 where where T is any
real number is any real number so this
is just a line with a slope of 2 right
you rise 2 for every one you go over so
let me draw my line just like this this
is nothing new at this point so that's
my let me draw it a little bit better
than that there you go and it keeps
going because obviously we can get
negative multiples of my vector and it
also goes here so you if you if you look
at all of the points that are specified
by all of the scaled up or scaled down
or negative scaled versions of this
vector you're going to get all the
points on this line if you draw those
vectors in standard position so this is
my line right there now I want to
construct a linear transformation that
reflects around this line for example if
I have this vector let me draw it like
this let's say I have that vector that
specifies that point right there let me
call that vector X I want the
transformation of X to be essentially
the reflection of X around this line so
if I go in this direction right here I
want this to be the transformation I
want that to be the transformation of X
so it should look just like that I'll do
another example let's say I have this
vector let's say I have let me give you
a particular vector let's say I have a
vector that's orthogonal to my line so
let's say I have the vector I'll call it
v1 and let's see something that's
orthogonal to it I can switch
these two guys and make one of them
negative so if I go to if I go to the
vector 2 minus 1 so if I have this
vector right here visually it looks
orthogonal so if I have V 2 let me call
it V 1 V 1 is equal to is equal to 2
minus 1 visually it looks orthogonal but
then even if you actually take the dot
product 2 times 1 plus minus 1 times 2
that's going to be equal to 0 so this is
definitely orthogonal to my spanning
vector so it's definitely worth talking
to every point on that line but if I
apply the transformation to this guy
right here I'm just going to flip it
over the line so let me draw it like
this so it's going to be equal to it's
just going to look like let me do it in
a green color so the transformation of
this guy I'm just flipping them over
this line I'm finding the reflection
across line now so this is going to be
the transformation the transformation of
v1 and it would be it would be you know
we don't know what the actual
transformation matrix is and that's
actually going to be the subject of this
video but if you just look at the
transformation just for a view 1 it's
going to be the negative of that so it's
going to be minus 2 minus 2 1 so I know
I want to define this transformation I
know I want to define this
transformation from R 2 to R 2 that is a
reflection so the transformation the
transformation of some vector X is the
reflection the reflection of X around or
cross or however you want to describe it
around line L around L now in the past
if we wanted to find the transformation
matrix we know this as a linear
transformation I don't have to go
through go through all of the exercises
of this is a linear transformation but
in the past if we wanted to find the
transformation matrix for linear
transformation so let's say we say T of
X is equal to some two-by-two matrix
because it's the mapping from R 2 to R 2
times X before in the past to find a
we would say a is equal to the
transformation applied to our standard
our first bit standard basis vector so
the transformation applied to one zero
and then our second column in a would be
the transformation applied to zero one
and if we were dealing in a in a in RN
we would do this end times and we would
have the n basis vectors we've seen this
multiple multiple times now in the past
when we were constructing these
transformation matrices finding these
things were pretty straightforward but
you'll see now it's not that
straightforward if I have if I have one
zero if I have the vector 1 0 finding
its transformation if I were to flip it
over it's going to look something like
this and we could do it if we if we were
able to be if we were creative with our
geometry in our trigonometry we could
actually figure this number out and we
could figure this number out if I were
to flip if I were to flip 1 if I were to
flip 0 1 over it would might look
something like that we could figure it
out but it's not easy so let me just
write this down it's not easy not easy
and we want to at least I mean you know
we could do this if we had to but if
there's an easier way we should at least
be exposed to that easier way so you
might have an insight here we've been
talking about alternate coordinate
systems and this transformation it looks
difficult in our standard coordinate
system because we're reflecting around
this line right there but what if we
defined a coordinate system or
reflection around this line was more
natural and you might already see an
interesting coordinate system what if we
had a coordinate system with v1 as one
of the basis vectors and then 1/2 as the
other basis vector and 1/2 as the other
basis vector then all of a sudden at
least in that coordinate system the
reflection wouldn't be around this you
know this inclined line the reflection
would be around the second coordinates
axis it seems like would be a more
natural transformation so this leads us
to a very interesting thing maybe let me
review what we've done in the last
couple of videos the last couple of
videos we could say look we're in
standard coordinates you apply some
you multiply by some matrix a and you
get the transformation of X we've seen
that multiple times this is in standard
coordinates and we've also seen that we
could change our coordinates we can get
coordinates with respect to some other
basis we can multiply X times C inverse
and then we'll get the representation of
X with respondents with respect to some
other basis and then we can multiply
that times some other matrix D and we've
seen let me write this down that D D is
equal to C inverse times a times C we
showed this to video I think was two or
three videos ago where C is just the
change of basis matrix it's just C is
just the matrix that has our new basis
vectors as columns and C inverses
obviously its inverse so we can apply D
and then if we multiply D times this B
coordinate version of X we will get the
B coordinate version we will get the B
coordinate version of the transformation
of X so the transformation of X
represented in B coordinates and then
you know you could convert back and
forth between these guys you could go
this way if you multiply by C inverse
you could go that way if you multiply C
we've seen this in multiple videos now
in this particular case that we're
dealing with I want to find a I want to
you know I've kind of defined my
transformation to kind of touchy-feely
terms I've just verbally defined it but
I would like to have a transformation
matrix with respect to my standard basis
but I just showed you that it's not easy
I'll have to break out you know some
serious geometry and trigonometry to
figure out you know what happens to one
zero when I reflect around the line
spanned by one two it's not easy but
what if we change basis what if we
change basis to some new basis let's say
we define some new basis where our
spanning vectors or our basis vectors
are this guy are the vectors to one and
the vectors one two one two so you can
almost view that our new horizontal axis
obviously it's not horizontal but if you
want to think of it this way is going to
be bit like that and our new vertical
axis
our new vertical axis is like this and
now in this world our transformation is
just a reflection around our new
vertical axis so maybe it'll be easier
maybe it'll be easier to find D because
this might be a simpler transformation
in this other coordinate system and then
if we can find D then we can solve for a
and we've seen this a is just equal to C
times D times C inverse I showed that to
you a couple of videos ago so let's see
if it's easier to find D so let's let's
just experiment a little bit let's label
our transformation vectors let's create
this is our basis vectors let's create
that's V 1 that's the same label I
applied to it over here let's save this
spanning vector right here of our line
that we're reflecting around let's call
that V 2 so our new coordinate system
has the basis vectors V 1 and V 2 now
what is what is the what is V 1 what is
V 1 represented in our new basis
remember when you transfer to a new
basis all it means is how much you have
your coordinates your first coordinate
now is going to be how much of your
first BEC basis vector do you need to
get a linear combination of V 1 and how
much of your second one well V 1 V 1 we
write it here V 1 is just equal to one
times v1 plus 0 times V 2 I mean if I
wanted to I could have found C inverse
and multiplied by it but you can it's
almost trivial to find a linear
combination of your basis vectors that
to get that gets V 1 in fact it's not
almost trivial it is trivial V 1 is 1
times v1 plus 0 times V 2 so it's
coordinates and in with respect to the
basis B are going to be 1 times v1 plus
0 times v2 fair enough now what is D
times what is D going to be let's say so
we want to let's say we want to find D
first because if we can find D we can
find D then we can just apply this
formula here
to figure out a now let's just say let's
just say that D is equal to D is equal
to it's going to be a two by two vectors
still mapping from r2 to r2 these are
this is still a two-dimensional space
it's going to map within this
two-dimensional space so let's say D has
just two column vectors D 1 and D 2 just
like that so what what is D times this
going to give us so let me write it this
way D let me scroll down a little bit
about I like to show that that little
chart right there but D times the B
coordinate version of our first basis
vector is going to be equal to D 1 D 2
those are the two columns of D D 1 D 2
times V 1 and B coordinates right so
it's going times 1 0 now what is this
going to be equal to what is this going
to be equal to well this is just going
to be you know this is just a linear
combination of these columns so it's
going to be 1 times D 1 1 times D 1 plus
0 times D 2 which is just D 1 so it's
the first column of this but what is
that also going to equal if I multiply D
times the times the B coordinate version
of X I've just gotten the B coordinate
version of the transformation of X so
this is going to be equal to and this is
going to be equal to the B coordinate
version the B coordinate version of the
transformation of the transformation of
v1 right if you just put a v1 here
instead of an X V ones B version right
there times D is going to be equal to
the transformation of v1 x' B version or
is it with or its coordinates with
respect to B so it's just that thing
right there
now do we know do we know what this so
there's a couple of interesting things
here we just got that the first column
just by applying this you know D times
this has got to be equal to this we just
figured out that the first column of D
right because you
take this x 1 0 which is the first basis
vectors representation in its own basis
and you're going to see in general that
when you represent these basis vectors
in their own basis they're going to look
just like your standard basis vectors in
this new coordinate system so when you
represented 2 1 in your new basis with
respect to this of course it's 1 times
this plus 0 times this it's going to be
1 0 if you have to represent if you want
to represent V 2 in your new basis well
what is it it's 0 times this guy plus 1
times this guy it's 0 times V 1 plus 1
times V 2 so it's going to be 0 1 and
you're gonna see this is generally the
case and when you think about it's
almost it's almost ridiculously obvious
that you know obviously if the first
basis vector is gonna be 1 times the
first basis vector plus 0 times the
second basis vector and if you had it
you know n basis vectors would be 1
times the first basis vector plus 0
times all of the other ones and if
you're in general if you're dealing with
let me go to it you know if you're
dealing with the nth basis vector and
you want it express it in your basis
you're essentially going to have you
know a bunch of zeros all the way
because one times your nth basis vector
and then everything else is 0 so this
will be the nth term so this applies
generally that you know disorder you can
call this e and if you want to call your
standard basis vectors that way this is
a bit of an aside I just want to show
you that this idea is generalizable now
what's useful about this well just
applying just applying this little you
know logic D times this guy is that guy
we figured out that the first column of
d is equal to the transformation applied
to our first basis vector in B
coordinates so if I wanted to rewrite D
I could write rewrite D like this the
first column is d 1 which is the same
thing as the transformation applied to V
1 our first basis vector in in B
coordinates now what is d 2 well let's
do the same thing to V 2 to our second
basis vector so if I multiply if I
multiply D time
the second basis vector v2 in B
coordinates right in our new coordinate
system that is equal to d1 d2 times what
is this guy's representation in a new
coordinate system it's 0 times v1 plus 1
times v2 it's 0 1 I wrote it up here
it's 0 1 so this is going to be equal to
0 times D 1 0 times D 1 plus 1 times D 2
which is equal to D 2 and what is that
going to be equal to if you multiply D
times some B coordinate representation
of X you're going to get the B
coordinate represents formation of X so
this is going to be equal to the B
coordinate representation of the
transformation of v2 v2 and just like
that we see that column 2 in D the
second column so this was the first
column the second column in D is just
this guy it's the transformation it's
the transformation of v2 in in B
coordinates in B coordinates now is this
any easier to find then this stuff up
here remember before we said hey we just
apply the transformation to the standard
basis vectors we can get the standard
transformation or we can find the
transformation matrix with respect to
the standard basis and that's what all
we wanted to do and we said that's not
easy is this any easier well what is the
transformation of v1 what is the
transformation of v1 let's go back to
our original transformation definition
this is v1 right here right the
transformation of v1 ended up being
minus v1 it equals minus v1 it equals
minus v1 so if we wanted to write the
transformation of v1 in B coordinates so
let me write this right here so the
transformation the transformation of v1
if I wanted to reflect it around the
line L it just was equal to minus v1
that's because V 1 was orthogonal to the
line right that
why we picked it if you just take the
transformation of this guy just flips
over and get the minus of the vector so
what is this guy if we want to apply it
if we wanted to write this in B
coordinates in B coordinates and B
coordinates well minus V 1 minus V 1 is
just equal to minus 1 times v1 plus 0
times V 2 so minus V one's coordinates
and B coordinates they're just going to
be equal to minus 1 times v1 plus 0
times v2 remember these are just the
weights on your basis vector so this
thing right here is pretty
straightforward this is just going to be
equal to minus 1 and 0 the first column
of D now what's the second column of D
it's the transformation of v2 v2 was the
vector that spanned our line this is v2
right here so what happens to v2 when
you transform it well you take the
reflection of something that's on the
line around that line it's just going to
be the same nothing's going to change
you're taking a reflection around this
I'm just going to kind of imagine
spinning that vector but it's not going
to change the vector at all right so the
transformation the transformation of
this guy of 1/2 is just going to be 1/2
the transformation of v2 is just going
to be equal to v2 let me write that down
the transformation the transformation of
v2 is just going to be equal to v2 as
you can see it's we pick these basis
vectors because transforming them was
very natural it was very easy so what
about this guy if I wanted to represent
this guy in B coordinates
well v2 and B coordinates we already
figured out is 0 1 so this is just going
to be 0 1 so now we have our our
transformation matrix D with respect to
basis B it is equal to the
transformation of our first basis vector
with respect to the B coordinates which
is minus 1 0 and then the second column
is the transformation of our second
basis vector with respect to the B
coordinate with respect to B coordinates
so it's 0 1 or the B coordinate
representation of the transformation of
our second basis
the language can get convoluted
sometimes and that was neat that was
easy
we've now have solved for D and now that
we've solved for D you notice that
changing the basis was actually very
natural and it was very easy to find
what D is and now that we know what D is
we can now solve for a we can now solve
for the transformation matrix with
respect to the standard basis so to do
that when we have to figure out C and C
inverse so C remember C is just the
change of basis matrix C is just the
change of basis matrix and that all that
is is the basis vectors it's just a
matrix with the basis vectors in the
column in a column so we have our basis
right here so C is just 2 1 and 1 2 and
then what is C inverse C inverse C
inverse is equal to well we have to find
that this guy's determinant so it's 2
times 2 which is 4 4 minus 1 times 1 so
it's 3 so we do 1 over the determinant 1
third times times you swap these dudes
right here so this is become a 2 and a 2
and then you make these two guys
negative negative 1 negative 1 that's C
inverse so now we're ready to solve for
a we're now ready to solve for a so a is
going to be equal let me pick a nice
color here a is going to be equal to C
which is 2 1 1 2 times D D is minus 1 0
0 1 times C inverse which is 1 3 2 minus
1 minus 1 2 so let's solve this let's
just do some matrix matrix products so
let's do this first
these two guys first and what do we get
we get we're gonna get a 2 by 2 matrix
we get 2 times minus 1 plus 1 times 0 so
this is going to be minus 2 and then
here you get 2 times 0 plus 1 times 1
plus 1 times 1 so you're just going to
get
right 2 times 0 plus 1 times 1 then here
1 times minus 1 plus 2 times 0 that's
just minus 1 and then you get 1 times 0
plus 2 times 1 that's just 2 and I'm
gonna have to multiply this times this
guy over here let me put the 1/3 out
front so we can worry about that later
and then let me multiply times this so
times 2 minus 1 minus 1/2 and all of
this is going to be equal to a I'll do
it in yellow so this is going to be
another 2 by 2 matrix and so we get we
get 2 times or negative 2 times 2 which
is minus 4 let me write it out so I
don't make careless mistakes minus 4 2
minus 2 times 2 plus 1 times minus 1 so
minus 1 that's that term right there the
next term is minus 2 times minus 1 which
is 2 plus 1 times 2 so plus 2 and then
let's do this term minus 1 times 2 is
minus 2 plus 2 times minus 1 which is
minus 2 and then finally we have minus 1
times minus 1 which is 1 plus 2 times 2
1 plus 4 make sure I did that right
minus 2 times 2 is minus 4 1 times minus
1 yeah I think I got it and of course we
have a 1/3 out front so this is going to
be equal to 1/3 times the matrix minus 4
minus 1 is minus 5 4 minus 4 and 5 or it
is equal to it is equal to minus 5/3 4/3
minus 4/3 and 5/3 that is our
transformation matrix a with respect to
the standard basis now let me check
something because I have a suspicion
because I did this before and I don't
have that what I did before in front of
me but I think I got a different answer
so let me just make sure I did this
correctly so see these are our basis
vectors right there let's see our basis
vectors where the vectors oh well our
first basis vector was a vector 2 minus
1 that's
where my error came from my first basis
vector was the vector 2 minus 1 and my
second basis vector is the vector 2 1 so
that obviously is going to change my C
it's going to change my C it won't
change anything else because we really
didn't use this information anywhere
else so it's going to be 2 minus 1 so C
is 2 minus 1 so C inverse C inverse
let's see the determinant is going to be
2 times 2 which is 4 minus minus 1 times
1 so it's going to be 4 plus 1 so this
is going to be a 5 sorry for the error
and then we're gonna switch these two
guys and then these two guys are going
to become negative so this guy is going
to become negative this guy is going to
be a plus let me rewrite that C inverse
apologize for the error C inverse is
going to be 2 1 minus 1/2 times 1/5 not
1/3 that's what that negative 1 changes
and so what are we going to get there's
going to be 2 minus this is C inverse
right here so it going to be 2 minus 1
this is a plus 1 and this is going to be
a 5 and then so this is going to be a 5
and this is going to be a plus 1 right
this thing wouldn't change actually this
will change because C is now 2 minus 1
actually let me just redo this part
because I realize that I've made it a
bit of a mess and just to go through
this and correct this it's a bit hairy
it's easier just to redo the whole
multiplication I apologize that
apologize for wasting your time with my
error so a is equal to let me rewrite
them to 1 minus 1/2 right 2 minus 1 1 2
that is our bait these are our basis
vectors I forgot that minus sign there x
times our vector d minus 1 0 0 1 our
matrix d times 1/5 let me just write the
1/5 out here times 1/5 this is C inverse
so we have 2 1 minus 1 2 and what is
this going to be equal to so first we
can do these two guys right there so
it's going to be 1/5 times
we have two times minus one plus one
times zero so it's minus 2 2 times 0
plus 1 times 1 is 1 right
if minus 1 times minus 1 plus 2 times 0
so that's just 1
and then minus 1 times 0 which is 0 plus
2 times 1 which is just 2 and then we
multiply it times this guy 2 minus 1 1 2
and what is this going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1/5 times
minus 2 times 2 is minus 4 plus 1 times
1 plus 1 and then your next term is
going to be minus 2 times minus 1 which
is 2 plus 1 times 2 so it's plus 2 and
we have 1 times 2 which is 2 plus 2
times 1 which is 2 right 1 times 2 plus
2 times 1 and then you have 1 times
minus 1 you have 1 times minus 1 which
is minus 1 plus 2 times 2 this is 4 so
this is going to be equal to 1/5 times
we have a minus 3 we have a 4 a 4 and a
minus 3 I'm sorry a plus 3 right minus 4
is minus 3 and then a plus 3 you can
imagine we deal with matrices the
arithmetic is what will trip you up so
your matrix a contrary to what I found
out a few minutes ago is equal to minus
3/5 minus 3/5 4/5 and then 4/5 3/5
just like that so borrowing my flight
arithmetic error when I got from writing
down the basis vectors incorrectly
forgetting to put that negative number
we now hopefully or you realize you can
appreciate we found an easier way to
find this transformation matrix a with
respect to the standard basis you find
the transformation matrix D first in a
more natural basis coordinate system and
then you can solve for a from that and
you get this result down there which is
hopefully the right answer if my memory
serves me right this is what I got
first time I did the problem